The Joe Rogan Experience well I think
the casuals got woken up to in the
Dustin Poirier Conor McGregor fight yeah
in that fight where you just see how
he's just so compromised and even fights
where you don't think that the guys
compromise like arasania
Israel said after the fight he's like
you [__] my leg up my legs you watch
it in the replay I didn't notice it even
because I was upstairs watching it and
then when they started showing the
highlights later on I was like well he
like went down from the one check too so
he checked it really weird and Well he
kind of got tripped over his foot and
then went down so we said oh he just
stumbled but it was really because his
leg wasn't working well already yeah
yeah it was the first round I went and
I've watched that fight several times
and uh apparently so has uh
apparently he puts it on yeah
um I watched it again and it's that
first round that first round he [__]
really chops at it really he's got a
very strange style it's very uniquely
Pareto his yeah the stand-up style it's
very different like his hands he he
stands like this he's just freakishly
long and big for that weight class and
his powers Preposterous you can you ever
see some of those guys like when you
look at certain skinny guys and I'm not
calling him he's not like he's lean but
he's lean and he's tall and lean those
guys are the guys I worry about because
it's those guys that hit freakishly hard
that it's the the big muscle guys you
know that guy's gonna hit you hard but
it's these sneaky tall lean guys Tommy
Hearns looking good yeah and they just
they when they turn into those hooks
he's left hook so much torque and
leverage his [__] left hook is a
thing of beauty man it really is
I mean his uh everything is [__] sick
he's such a scary guy and the high level
kickboxing experience that he has like
coming over from Glory I'm you know I'm
very interested to see what Israel does
different in the second fight but I'm
really interested in seeing him against
someone who can wrestle that's what I'm
really interested in I was just going to
say it's kind of working out perfectly
for Alex where
you get another you get another shot
yeah you know you get to go and face
Israel again that's the best matchup for
you you got a guy that is probably going
to stand with you for as long as the
fight lasts yeah when he's really going
to get challenged is when he has
somebody that's going to say that Marvin
vittori yeah I'm gonna grapple your ass
I'm gonna pressure you up against the
fence and for guys like Victoria it's
got to be like all right they want him
to stay the champ yeah because Izzy
already had their number and he's been
there but as long as pereira's in there
another kickboxer but with a different
style maybe not as much experience in
the grappling Department they're
chomping into bit to get in there well
Robert Whittaker you know Whitaker's
very well-rounded he's he's an
interesting matchup for him there's
there's a very good matchups in that 185
pound division but in my opinion what's
interesting is
he's a specialist he's like a pure
specialist yeah I mean he's he can
grapple a little bit but that's not what
he wants to do he wants to knock your
[__] head into the bleachers yeah and
you know it going in you know that's
what he wants to do to you we just try
to I mean is he was winning that fight
and he's still got him out of there yep
I couldn't believe it I remember even
saying that people were watching it up
in the ESPN desk were like man could you
imagine if he pulls it off here in the
end and he [__] did it yeah he did it
Izzy was probably ahead three well what
how many rounds do you think he was
ahead going into that
fifth round that was the fifth and I
think even that round was was that who I
I don't remember now well is he
definitely won the first and almost
knocked him out I think he had probably
two or three rounds
yeah it's hard to say I'd have to go
back and try to score it
which I'm terrible at man people are
always like what did you think I'm like
I'm calling the fight yeah you can't
call and that's the score at the same
time I don't get it when you're scoring
a fight you should shut your mouth
okay here we go so uh Izzy had three
rounds on Eric Cohen's card on Sal
dimada's card he had uh three rounds and
he also has everybody rounds and Mike
Bells yeah so he's all the same too all
he had to do is move around yep
not get caught any wins that fight
wow
I'm very interested in the rematch very
because you got to think is he almost
had him out in the first round man he
almost had him out if he can avoid
getting that leg compromised like he did
in the first round of that fight and so
he's got his movement
and he also had some great moments
grappling which surprised a lot of
people yeah when he had potatoes back
and if there's a time that you're gonna
pull out some grappling it's in that
matchup that's what that do and he's
been at it longer than potatoes so it's
like that's the time to show and he did
yeah both guys did both guys I think
scored takedowns at one point or another
in that fight I remember being like Oh
now they're now they're wrestlers in
here you get two guys that know they can
knock the crap out of each other and
suddenly everybody knows how to do a
little bit of wrestling well just you
know the mixing it up just keeping
someone guessing over overload their
brain yeah 25 minutes of avoiding that
left hook
scary proposition it's everything man
everything he hits you with is hard
that's what I'm talking about those lean
guys like that you know those shins hurt
you know if he lands an elbow on you
same as Izzy the similar build but
Alexa has more muscle on him he's quite
a bit bigger I mean I think potato when
he actually wade into the fight was
above 220. yeah when he was inside the
Octagon before the fight was above 220
whereas you gotta remember when Izzy
fought Jan bohovich for the light
heavyweight title he was only 194. yeah
I mean is he is Izzy's one of those guys
that's not cutting that much weight he's
not cutting anyway and even when he
wanted to go up to light heavyweight
he's like I'm not cutting any weight I'm
gonna fight as I fight